if the president ever were to be impeach
and I think it's a very very far-fetched
proposal if it were ever to happen it
would be bad for the economy and bad for
the market what we have here is an
anonymous alleged whistleblower who had
no direct knowledge of the facts gossip
is what it is in any court of law this
would be unadmitted
as hearsay it's a serious serious
allegation about the conduct of the
president it's not only a serious
allegation the process is seriously
flawed the notion that a defendant
doesn't have the ability to confront the
accuser and the accuser is bona fides
don't have to be brought under scrutiny
is patently ridiculous the fact is the
Democrats talked about impeachment the
day after the election
they've been hell-bent for leather to
impeachment looking for any pretext on
which to do it
first it was the Mueller report and then
when that turned out to be a nothing
ball thing
now suddenly mysteriously the
intelligence community relaxed the rules
on whistleblower it's be very
interesting to find out just how did
that come about it's very convenient you
think it's a conspiracy I'm not much of
a conspiracy theorist but it does make
one wonder and then the very careful
packaging of it to hit during the UN
when the president was making great
achievements that is kind of a
conspiracy theory isn't it saying this
mysteriously happens well all I can say
is it's mysterious it should be looked
into I'm confident it will be looked
into he's spoken to the president speak
to the president every day has a how's
he feeling about this oh he's in good
spirits in general because he knows not
shaken I am fishing we're accomplishing
what we set out to which is helped the
American worker help American business
and move the economy forward that's what
he's happy about he's obviously very
unhappy
the with this process because it's not a
proper process they talk about a
cover-up well how was it a cover-up when
the president voluntarily not under
subpoena but voluntarily released the
transcripts of the conversation then
held a joint press conference with the
other party the whole kind of a cover of
the slap you're here in the UK obviously
talking to American businesses I'm
wondering how you feel they feel Brax it
is going well they're very nervous
they've spent the better part of the
billion dollars on preparatory measures
to try to mitigate whatever problems
might come but they're very very
uncertain about the outcome and
particularly worried about supply chain
implications and the sheer logistics of
moving goods we hope that things can be
worked out in the least disruptive way
between the UK and the EU but regardless
of how they're worked out we intend to
make a very quick free-trade agreement
with the UK and you your department has
instituted the ban on Huawei and the US
but the UK still works with Huawei here
and we still you know have potential
involvement with them when it comes to
5g networks does that discomfort you
well I think it should discomfort the UK
so I make the analogy if you were about
to buy a new car but there was a 10%
chance you'd be killed because of a
defect in the car and the first time you
drove it would you buy the car I don't
think so well I promise you there's far
more than a 10 percent chance of
something untoward in Huawei 5g
equipment